flex hallo ich will mein blog
ja und was geht hier soll max nicht
willkommen aus österreich zusammen mit
israel
sie hat eine bewegungsfreundliche meine
was genau mein name ist demonstrieren
juli also leute verstehst du deswegen
alle deine videos und abonnieren
okay leute ich hatte so ein richtig
schön chaos quatsch one take a der
leider verloren gegangen ist weil das du
mikrofon keinen ton aufgenommen hat erst
mal was machen wir hier wir sind in
österreich
wir das sind peter luisi sg und ich und
wir sind hier für eine produktion von
der ufa wo wir unter anderem zocken und
auch so winteraktivitäten machen also
viel verraten natürlich nicht das kommt
dann irgendwann später auf dem kanal von
der ufa ich hätte euch natürlich dann
auch rechtzeitig informieren darüber und
es wird richtig richtig cool also sind
heutigen gefahren so sieben stunden von
köln aus und es war so lustig also wir
nur quatsch gemacht
sebastians allein gekommen peter easy
und ich sind werden von köln aus
gefahren und zwar richtig richtig lustig
also deshalb bin ich auch sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir ein paar tage
hier verbringen werden auch wenn es
klappt nur mit dem hier sogar nur drei
stück sind aber mal schauen ob wir
morgen noch ski fahren gehen oder sonst
fast und ja wir sind in österreich bei
salzburg so grob die richtung und ich
werde euch einfach mal sagen was wir so
machen eigentlich so ein quatsch
quatsch quatsch von taker machen aber
das hat leider nicht geklappt wegen
dem boden mikrofon wir hatten schon so
richtig tollen quatsch gemacht ich
intensiv online
aber ja ich bin jetzt gerade hier in
meinem zimmer und hört vielleicht so
leicht im hintergrund peter und mein
bruder zocken fifa der klever hingehen
und sie schneidet da oben sein blog der
hier noch mal so eine ausführliche
wohnhaus tour ein quatsch video hier
oben hessen wir hier sitzt ein ist es
nicht was ich gemacht habe
doch nicht sagen sagt nichts
ich habe auch einfach erklärt was wir
machen in diesem video dazu ihr leid ich
musste das video machen weil wir den
ganzen tag schon nur scheiße reden
und hier sind menschen halte ich für ein
gerücht und es hält der nach dem film
gericht
und hier hat ist für hunde 360° videos
eines staates ist wahr wir drin was ein
360 grad
wozu machst du das video leute kennt die
ganzen leute gar nicht das bestimmt
vollkommen komisches video
das kind
love like da